[Music]
the first cars movie hit the big screens
in 2006 and the franchise immediately
took over the world almost 11 years
later we finally got to see Lightning
McQueen and the rest of his gang in
action again but wait until you see what
Lightning McQueen looks like in real
life give this video a thumbs up and hit
that subscribe button if you love cars
now fasten your seat belts because we're
about to show you 10 cars characters in
real life Doc Hudson let's start with
the car who's racing days are long
behind him but he still manages to steal
every scene in the movie doc is one of
the oldest cars but that doesn't really
slow him down his first race dates back
to 1951 and although doc is now old he's
inspired by lightning McQueen's young
spirit and ambitions if you haven't seen
any of the movies we promise we won't
spoil cars for you but you should
definitely watch it because you'll fall
in love with Duck Duck Hudson is based
on the fabulous Hudson Hornet and his
character is a tribute to the car that
was once one of the most competitive
race cars on the market the car is so
popular that people are building a lot
of replicas of the vehicle but there can
only be one real version of Hudson
Hornet so yes the fabulous Hudson Hornet
actually exists in real life and there
are many old-school drivers out there
with fond memories of this car doc is
voiced by Paul Newman one of the biggest
movie legends Paul himself has a huge
passion for cars in general but he said
that the team behind the franchise is
what's most interesting about these
movies since filming the first Cars
movie in 2006 Paul is retired from
acting and only came back to film the
sequel and now cars three Mac do you
remember Jerry recycled batteries from
the first Cars movie and how he hated
being called a Mac because he was a
Peterbilt truck well meet the other
truck also known as Mack the hauler
truck Mack appears in all three cars
movies we love his character because he
values teamwork and loves being on the
road he's the one that transports
lightning McQueen to all his races he's
loyal trusted and he
gets the job done well unless he falls
asleep but you're going to have to watch
the movies if you want to see that story
max attention to detail is amazing have
you ever paid attention to his Bulldog
ornament you're actually able to get a
real-life hood ornament like that then
these Bulldogs date back to 1932 if you
spend a lot of time on a highway you've
probably seen a couple of Macs in real
life these trucks are some of the oldest
most powerful and most durable trucks
around their company the Mack Brothers
company is actually older than the
famous Ford Motor the Mack trucks are
also nicknamed Bulldog Mack's for their
amazing power and performance which also
explains the Bulldog ornaments sure a
real-life version of Mack can't talk and
probably doesn't know Lightning McQueen
but you can't say these trucks aren't
some of the most powerful trucks you've
ever seen the actual Mack from cars is
voiced by John Ratzenberger who had a
role in movies like wall-e Toy Story and
up miss Ritter
since there's so much buzz about the
third Cars movie let's explore some of
the new characters on the scene one of
them is Miss fritter sure she looks like
a school bus but she's not an ordinary
yellow school bus Miss Ritter comes with
two exhaust pipes that are shaped like
horns who doesn't want to see a school
bus having a race with some of the
biggest race cars out there of course if
you want to see Miss Ritter in real life
you won't have to look far in fact you
probably see her every single day if you
still go to school her character was
based on Ford B series school buses that
were around from 1948 to 1998 later
those buses were sold to another
manufacturer and nowadays Ford no longer
makes school buses miss Britt er is a
very last Ford school bus you will ever
see in action we can't wait to see what
she'll be up to do you know that Miss
Ritter is played by no other than Lea
delaria yes she also plays big boo in
orange is the new black Lea added a few
personal touches to Miss fritter the
license plate is actually her birthday
and the name of the school on the bus
was Lea's actual school how cool is that
strip the cake
weathers let's mix it up a little and
add a character who appeared in all cars
movies and he also appears in cars
three-strip is a veteran racer who won
the pits in cuffs seven times these
races were a total piece of cake for him
until he got himself injured but those
are all spoilers we'll give you today
strip is a blue Plymouth Superbird with
a number 43 on his side
he's kind caring and completely selfless
he's based on a real-life Plymouth
Superbird car built in the 1970s to
accommodate the ever-growing demand for
race cars after the car was brought in
the game the company behind it won 75
percent of overall races which is pretty
impressive it's safe to say that strip
was the best car of his time even though
he wouldn't be able to compete with
modern race cars his voice belongs to
Richard Petty a retired race car driver
yes the cars franchise actually features
voices of some of the most iconic
racecar drivers ever stripped story line
in the first movie was inspired by
Richard's actual life story Richard who
always thought Hollywood never gave
enough credit to his sport was very
impressed by the detail in cars and
there you have it this Disney movie is a
racecar driver approved Luigi let's move
on to perhaps one of our favorite cars
characters ever do you love Luigi we're
right there with you and guess what he
managed to come back in cars three how
can you not love this Ferrari obsessed
car with an Italian accent Luigi is kind
funny and he steals every single scene
he's in although he's a background
character he often takes the spotlight
Luigi is a yellow colored Italian Fiat
500 if you've ever been to Italy you've
probably seen quite a few similar cars
that look exactly like Luigi Fiat 500 is
iconic
once you see it you can't help but to
think of Italy and with that you're
probably thinking about pizza right now
sorry wrong video today we're talking
about cars have you ever seen the
numbers of Luigi's license plate they
actually represent the latitude and
longitude of Modena the city where
Ferrari was
actually found it Luigi really is
Ferraris number-one fan Luigi is voiced
by Tony Shalhoub's who's actually not
Italian even though he played several
Italian characters during his career
with Luigi being a side character
Tony noted that he feels like he won the
lottery when the Ferrari loving car
returned for the sequel and now the
third movie mater mater is probably one
of the most popular characters out there
if you struggle how to pronounce his
name here's how he explains it like tow
mater but without the tongue
much like Luigi mater is a
happy-go-lucky character that somewhat
naive but at the same time very caring
and kind you can't help but love him
although he's forgetful at times he's
very optimistic fun and instantly
lovable the inspiration for his
character came from old tow trucks which
is why it's so easy to find mater
practically anywhere we can imagine
these trucks won't be as fun as this
Disney character mater's voice belongs
to Daniel Lorenz Whitney whom you
probably know as Larry the Cable Guy
which is his stand-up comedy persona and
although mater has a much bigger role in
the second movie Larry said his favorite
is still the first we can't wait to see
what he thinks about cars three do you
want to hear something cool about mater
every month
Larry spend some time talking on a phone
to children from st. Jude Children's
Hospital in his unique mater voice not
only is mater kind and caring on camera
but it also looks like his loving spirit
is making a difference in real life -
just one more reason to add mater to
your list of favorite characters
Francesco Bernoulli and who can forget
Francesco Bernoulli the competitive and
tagging Asst of cars - Francesco is an
international formula champion who never
fails to win a race he is lightning
McQueen's main rival and he's definitely
not the nicest characters out there
Francisco is a Formula One race car
painted to represent Italy where he
first learned how to race
although Francesco is seen as
self-centered
he's not entirely terrible but you'll
have to watch the movies to see why his
last
is a tribute to Daniel Bernoulli a Swiss
mathematician who invented the
Bernoulli's theorem of fluid dynamics
but the actual car is of course a
tribute to Ferrari one of the most
iconic race cars that ever existed first
Formula One Championship idea dates back
to 1946 and the first actual race took
place in 1950 Ferrari still gives a
thrill to many racecar drivers out there
with Michael Schumacher being one of the
biggest race car driver icons there is
although Francesco's not one of the
nicest characters out there his
competitiveness and the thrill to win is
a representation of many drivers out
there his character is voiced by John
Turturro who's also known as agent
Simmons in transformers
although Francesco was only there for
one movie he managed to leave an
impression with all Ferrari and Formula
one fans do you think Francesca will
ever make a comeback red even though he
has a simple name red has one of the
most important jobs out of all cars
characters his personality might be the
most surprising out of all characters
we've mentioned so far you see red is
not your typical fire truck he's fearful
he's tearful he's quite clumsy as a
firetruck he's of course also supportive
and protective when he needs to be his
look is very typical and you can pretty
much find a real-life version of red in
every city did you know that the very
first versions of fire trucks were just
water pumps on wheels
firefighters had to pull the pump to
reach the fire which wasn't exactly
ideal
the very first fire engine was built in
1841 in New York fire trucks are
actually produced by Mack trucks whom
we've mentioned before and even though
fire trucks are meant to be powerful and
mighty we can't help but love the
fearful red Reds voice belongs to the
late Joe wrench who was not only a
talented voice actor but he also
co-directed cars the movie his brother
Jerome rents a Disney character sculptor
later voiced red in cars toons Pixar
described Joe as one of the creative
spark plugs who
the production engines humming Sally
Carrera next in line is Sally Carrera
who sometimes refers to our next
character as stickers instead of calling
him by his real name but it's okay
because she's his girlfriend Sally is
charming and incredibly witty and she's
Radiator Springs town attorney she
appears in all three movies Sally used
to be a very famous attorney who decided
she didn't want all that fame and
fortune this is why she initially came
to Radiator Springs and found love
instead if you're looking for a
real-life version of Sally you'll have
to keep an eye out for a Porsche Porsche
cars have been around since 1948 these
high-performance independent cars have
really carved out the name for
themselves and Porsche is still one of
the most wanted and iconic cars out
there Porsche cars have won around
24,000 auto races around the world not
only are they beautifully designed but
they're also insanely fast and they're
still taking the racing world by storm
Sally Carrera is definitely a fantastic
tribute to be as iconic racecars Sally's
voice belongs to Bonnie Hunt who also
voiced dolly on the Toy Story and Flint
in Monsters Inc the charming Bonnie who
said she identifies with Sally's
decision to leave fortune and fame
behind actually also got writing credit
for Sally's character no wonder Sally's
so witty Lightning McQueen but the cars
movies wouldn't exist without the star
of the show Lightning McQueen is easily
one of the most popular characters out
there at first he's quite arrogant and
selfish until he learns that he has to
work hard to be the best eventually he
becomes the talk of the town and gets on
the good side of the Radiator Springs
locals unlike other cars in the movie
Lightning McQueen isn't based on any
real-life car he's a brand new invention
and even the animators said they found
his character boring as a regular stock
car so they polished him up into the
race car you know today he features a
beautiful red paint job and plenty
stickers along with his signature number
95 as the new kid on the block Lightning
McQueen has a lot to prove but over the
three movies he realizes there are more
important things out there than winning
because of his unique looks the real
Lightning McQueen can only be found in
the cars land his character is voiced by
Owen Wilson who had roles in some of the
biggest Hollywood movies out there in an
interview
Owen mentioned cars four could be in the
works following lightning McQueen's
story development from the third movie
and we can't wait to see it who's your
favorite cars character let us know in
the comments and that's it for ten cars
characters in real life for more videos
check out 10 Despicable Me characters in
real life see you next time
[Music]